on s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait
énormément de personnes énormément de
femmes qui se sentent en insécurité seul
dans les milieux festifs et qu'il était
temps d'agir
[Musique]
avec 2 milliards à vos j'ai 27 ans et je
suis une des co fondatrice de
l'association consentis qui lutte contre
les violences sexuelles en milieu festif
et qui promeut le consentement dans les
boîtes de nuit les festivals et les
salles de bronze le déclic on l'a lu
pendant le mouvement mitu qui a posé
massivement et publiquement le problème
des violences sexuelles dans l'espace
public pour autant on s'est rendu compte
qu'il y avait assez peu d'action qui
étaient mises en place dans le milieu
qui nous étaient chers donc le milieu de
la fête le milieu des boîtes de nuit et
des festivals et c'est là qu'on a eu
envie d'agir on a commencé l'association
en faisant une enquête en fait en
sondant les fêtards allait fêtarde et on
s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait
énormément de personnes énormément de
femmes qui se sentaient en insécurité
seul dans les milieux festifs et qu'il
était temps d'agir
[Musique]
qu'on a vu en allemagne c'était qu'il y
avait des initiatives des choses à
mettre en place dans les milieux festifs
à les boîtes de nuit mais tu es par
exemple des chartes à l'entrée et on a
trouvé ces initiatives hyper inspirante
et on a eu envie de les ramener en
france
[Musique]
cet atelier il va parler de consentement
de jeu non sexistes et sexuelles et ça
peut parfois faire remonter des choses
du coup petit rigueur warning à toulouse
avait besoin d'aller marcher faire un
tour vous dégourdir souffler un coup il
ya pas de problème
[Musique]
deux femmes sont dans le chill apps dont
kate mccann de la soirée elles
s'embrassent individus s'assoit à côté
d'elle avec un sourire narquois leur
parle ils haussent le ton donc l'oeuvre
dans le canapé en face n'entendait pas
totalement la conversation mais vous
intercepter les mots plan à trois est
excité et vous voyez que les femmes sont
gênés par la présence d'individus et ses
propos qu'est-ce que je fais là prendre
tout ce qu'on va faire c'est se demander
est-ce que je suis témoin de quelque
chose qui pour moi formation en soirée
par exemple de me dire je vois quelque
chose pour moi c'est grave
on accompagne les orga dans la mise en
place de dispositifs de prévention va
les former qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
quand on est au regard pour réduire se
sentir en insécurité et ses violences
sexuelles en milieu festif on les forme
à accueillir la parole des victimes on
les forme en qualification juridique des
violences sexuelles on va également
recommandé de briefer le personnel de
sécurité et s'il faut bien briefé le
personnel de sécurité sur quelque chose
c'est qu'il faut croire les victimes
parce qu'on voit souvent dans les
témoignages en fait que les victimes de
violences sexistes et sexuelles
cherchent de l'aide et souvent elles ces
victimes ne sont pas cru ne sont pas sur
ton look c'est hyper important de
briefer tout l'écosystème en fait sur
ces sujets
[Musique]
toujours été les organisateurs et
organisatrices qui venaient vers nous on
s'est assez vite rendu compte que nos
actions c'était quelque chose qui était
très attendu par contre depuis le
mouvement balance combat donc il ya 10
et les violences sexuelles en milieu
festif on est un peu plus proactifs et
là on a contacté justement pas mal de
bach pas mal de bois de lits pour mettre
en place des actions parce qu'il est
temps de le faire et je dirais aussi que
quand on aligne des ateliers quand on
tient des stands directement milieu
festif on a beaucoup de retours en fait
de personnes qui viennent nous voir pour
nous remercier en fait d'être présent et
présente parce que notre présence nous
couler rassure une fois sur instagram on
a reçu un message privé d'une personne
qui remerciait tout en nous envoyant un
seul fit d'elle avec l'unc robes tops et
qui me disait que c'était grâce à nous
aussi ce soir là elle sortait du coup
avec un croc top seul dans une boîte de
nuit et qu'elle se sentait plus libre et
donc ça c'est vraiment notre objectif
c'est pour ça qu'on se barre
[Musique]